foreign
yeah yeah go ahead from the beginning
right yeah okay
here are some things that guys need to
watch out for when they're dating
regardless of the size of your
pocketbook or your dreams or aspirations
and ignore these things at your peril
because just like all the Great Men of
antiquity the Bible and in the past a
woman can need to help but oftentimes
the wrong woman can throw a man
completely into chaos start off with
this one she wants to be courted yep she
wants to be quoted now I know there's
some guys are probably thinking Hey
Kevin you kind of talk like a
traditional man what's wrong with her
wanting to be courted nothing if she's
truly a traditional woman but typically
women want to be courted because they
want all the benefits of traditional
femininity and gender roles the thing
bringing none of that stuff to the table
this is just another way of asking you
to simp very few westernized women
deserve to be courted I say it again
very few westernized women deserve to be
courted you guys fought for equality
you're my equal you wanted equal pay you
wanted equal rights or you need to get
equal lefts you want to be courted that
ain't gonna happen we are equals deal
with it thank feminism one-on-one your
Mamas and your grandmamas this is the
world ladies if you're watching
understand this is what men are on the
lookout for so if you asking some guy to
court you what are you bringing to the
table other than sex and debt she's got
a 90-day rule or any kind of rule like
this in my opinion the first time I hear
a woman say she's got a 90-day rule I'm
out the first time I hear a woman talk
about this rule or any other kind of
rule like that I'm out just like the
United States had a policy we do not
negotiate with terrorists women can be
emotional terrorists I do not negotiate
with them because if you give a mouse a
cookie It'll ask for a glass of milk she
has a 90-day rule that automatically
implies to me that she thinks her vagina
is gold that it's something that that
gum important that I have to work strive
and earn for I don't work that hard for
anything that doesn't benefit me her
vagina ain't it because if you have
these 90 Day rules go out and blame all
these Steve Harvey type guys who told
you guys this foolishness that is man
repellent rule on day one in the other
89 days it'll be you playing with your
cat is next she's a single mother I'm
not going to ban single mothers anything
like that but bottom line there used to
be a time when a woman had a baby out of
wedlock it was few and far between and
there was some shame that went along
with it enough to where they didn't keep
going out and doing it over and over
again now it's a badge of honor you as a
man are worth too much and too valuable
if you got your head on straight you're
out doing your thing working your
business taking care of your business
you should not be forced to pick from a
crop of women who've already had another
man's children you should not have to go
out here and fight the world build touch
and so forth to come home to a woman
that you will at best be the fourth or
fifth most important thing in her life
you deserve better than that I am sorry
ladies if you've had a child that is
your responsibility own it and as far as
I'm concerned stay out of the dating
scene until your kids are out of the
house you made the choice to have those
children especially if you did it
outside of wedlock you may their choice
then you make the choice to wear that
Scarlet Letter it's not our problem it's
yours guys do not date single mothers do
it at your apparel next she's a strong
independent fill in the blank woman for
me you have three times to say good five
strong Independence I'm a strong
independent blank woman I'm a strong
independent check please I'm gone
anytime that comes out of their mouth
non-negotiable in the sentence whether
it's day one or day 300 because to me
that's an underlying issue that's
waiting to burst through it's a person
who has to say I'm a strong independent
anything is none of the things she says
just like if you find yourself having to
come into your house saying I'm the man
of this house you got to say you're the
man of the house there's a problem if
you watch Game of Thrones when Joffrey
says I'm the king and Taiwan told him
any kid any man who has to say he's the
king is not the king
strong independent blank anything needs
to be strong independent and alone she
believes that men and women are equals
we are not equals no male and female of
any species on the planet are equal we
are different for a reason I am not
going to negotiate your role and my role
if you come into this saying that we're
equal we're automatically at loggerheads
because you're not a woman in my opinion
you're a female I don't date females I
date women just like the men will hear
what I'm saying the males will probably
throw shade if you want a woman that
you're equal you're really giving your
manhood up and I can't help you for the
guys out there who are trying to hear me
equality is not what is cracked up to be
typically women want equality when it
benefits them and they want to be ladies
when it suits them I don't have time for
all the back and forth because I'm
trying to do what I'm doing I'm leading
she's going to follow there can't be two
captains pick your poison if you pick
equality you'll die a slow day she's a
big time church girl I'm a Christian I
was born and raised in the church I
attend regularly but big time Church
girls tend to come with Big Time Church
problems there's no more hypocrisy in
dating than in the church because unless
she's a big time church girl and a
virgin you're already going to have
issues oftentimes Big Time Church girls
try to use the Bible as a weapon against
the men that they date to hold you
biblically accountable for everything
that says a man should be but yet not
hold themselves biblically morally or
ethically accountable to anything that
it says a woman should be they'll tend
to take scriptures out of context use
biblical stories for their own selfish
and manipulative ends and hit you in a
place to where you really can't defend
your spirituality that is the height of
manipulative deceptive bad behavior I
don't roll with Big Time church Bible
Thumpers but these primary reasons if it
doesn't suit you move on but you know
the kind of person I'm talking about
she's got lots of single girls okay you
can stop it you ever see a pack of
animals roaming in there that that's my
point
so it's like
the women can basically do whatever they
want come to God say sorry and still
demand Church outcomes
and if the guy doesn't go with it then
he's the bad guy for not wanting to
follow God
and and I I understand it's like the
girls will say oh I don't want to add
into my body count I don't want to make
it worse maybe I learned from my
mistakes but guys we just have to listen
to How the men hear it
this sounds crazy to men blessing you
want to wait for a born-again virgin
you put in a ring you wait until
marriage
and blessings a a religious good dude
but he's not putting no are you putting
up with that nah
and and this is the this is the thing
it's
we're so conditioned to want
not even conditioned women want no
consequences for decisions if you made
the decision to not wait till you're
married how on Earth are you going to
demand marriage later that doesn't make
sense
feel free to do the call-in
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible